you'll be able to watch it again oh
maybe I'm on now okay good so hello
hello welcome to another computer music
business the of the halloween version
i'm going to have another Christmas
lecture in December the next one and
topic today is play to logic computing
which I you know I figure if if I use a
word that nobody knows somebody has to
come in here and hear the talk right so
i will i will at least explain to you
but before you leave you will know what
what that means and in fact it's a it's
something that I'm right now writing
part of volume 4 of the art of computer
programming which is which is kind of
the part that I've been waiting longest
force you know for so many years I've
been collecting material for section
which is now called section 7.1 point 3
and at the end and now at last I can put
it into you know into a computer file
and pretty soon it's going to be out
there for everybody to read and sort of
this is they I mean I've enjoyed writing
the rest of the book but this part is
the part that that really I i like the
most somehow anna and so i hope other
people like it too I got it I got a you
know I'm fine start on it but I haven't
and so it's section what 713 is called
bitwise tricks and techniques my friend
Mike Patterson has a has his own name
for this he calls it be T and T now i
wish you know sort of a sequel to AT&T
but anyway this is this this will be on
the web available for downloading in a
month or so i'm still I'm still in the
midst of writing it if you if a few
people that actually guessed the URL and
found it you know think the the the
rough draft but but I know unless you
have a lot of time there's so much other
stuff you
do no point in it can read until I've
until I've got the ready for beta
testing at lee Bailey this as I say I
have a terrific fun writing this because
I've been collecting stuff from the
folklore that that programmers have been
doing for years and years and rarely
does it get into print nowadays there's
about a dozen websites that of people
that have also found their own
collection of these off of these tricks
and and so I looked at all those
websites some of them at least one of
them is hosted at Stanford by shawn
anderson and and then a book came out at
23 years ago called hackers delight
which which features a lot of these
ideas and and there are arata to that
book on the web so you know an author
that book that we're in constant touch
though we were trading idea these are
these are our are things that at first
we thought they were just tricks but
once week 13 but you know the different
wiener trick and the technique is that a
technique as you get is something is
something that you can use at least
twice you know and so and so once you
know once you find two different
application for something then it
becomes a technique and and and we're
understanding more and more about it and
it might even be that we're just seeing
the tip of the iceberg that there's many
more of these things so my general
feeling is that that right now computer
scientists are about in the somewhat in
state analogous to the way at the at the
end of the 60s we were with respect to
data structures during the during the
first part of the 60s people were
learning about about data structures and
and but but the general idea was well if
you want to use anything more than a
then a linear list or you know I'm sorry
a vector or matrix then then you use
somebody's package you know
you used say list for something where
somebody has given you a whole bunch of
high level data structures but all of a
sudden programmers found out that that
actually they could do their own data
store he was pretty easy to you know to
use to make stacks themselves and and
and so on in their own programs and so
now I think it's about the same we're
about at that level with respect to the
to the stuff I'm talking about today
that it that it's time to go mainstream
with these with these ideas that that
would you know there now understand
enough we don't have to go to somebody
to some special compiler that knows how
to do some some fancy things but we can
actually understand the certain methods
and and use them in our own programs
with with ease and understanding and so
I'm hoping that this that that anyway
this this change that no do you aren't a
lot of the things I'm talking about
today are going to seem exotic but I'm
hoping that in 10 years you know it
won't be taught in it necessarily in
first grade but but but maybe you know
every programmer will sort of consider
that part of their basic toolkit now
took so what does it mean bitwise well
it's just that the true sir very
beginning computers have have had not
only the ability to add subtract
multiply and divide but they also had
the ability to do what we used to call
logical and or there are other names you
know so so you could take two binary
numbers unless you had a decimal
computer you could take two binary
numbers and you could and you could take
the end of the two things so you're just
getting a one where both of them into
positions where both of the numbers were
one and you also had or and you had
exclusive or which is in fact at one
point was uh was a classified thing I
went to the UH the army was he was used
so often in code breaking I went to a
conference in Los Alamos in 1976 where
somebody wrote the truth table for
exclusive or on the blackboard and the
security man erased it immediately
done huh anyway it's you know we can't
keep it a secret you know any longer so
so now now okay so so so so we're
exclusive or arm I write it as a class
wit in a circle this means that up you
know that this means that i take the
bits so let's suppose X is equal to five
right and put it in binary is 101 and y
is equal to well choose a number not too
big 7 all right all right that's a
that's it that's lucky so now it's so
exclusive or why you just take each bit
1 1 plus 1 but you added mod 2 so you
get 0 1 0 okay so so x 0 plus y is a is
too all right then you also have x and y
and I you see notation for this as
ampersand so this means you take the end
of all the bits and what do you get x
and y 5 okay then X or Y is 7 let's x
and y bar that is the complement of Y
bureau yeah and so on up any boolean
operation that we do know else we also
have like left shift okay x left shift
to would be 101 and we can we bring in
zeros and so this is a 2 and so this is
20 and an ex right shift 2 is one ok so
these are the basic bitwise operations
that we at now however I let me go to
something a little bit harder let's try
minus X I'm going to consider that these
are
integers but their infinite precision
integer so minus one is going to be all
ones you know one proceeding out
indefinitely what is minus five but you
know it's going to have a whole bunch of
ones at the beginning you know it's
minus five but but what does it look
like in binary looks like that because
if we add five to that we can check it
add five where you get one on one is to
carry one we do carry when we when we
add not when we do exclusive or one on
one is too okay there we go and we get
and we get him forget it in general in
fact if X is any of you know let's
suppose X is equal to alpha of n 1 and a
whole bunch of zeros then minus X is
equal to alpha bar and one and a whole
bunch of zeroes this is the complement
of alpha bitwise compliment I should
have also mentioned compliment you know
okay so because you know you add these
together and you get zero and then you
get one and one is two and then and then
here we getting 0 and 1 or 1 and 0
everywhere along so we're getting 0 all
the way around so this is the formula
for 4-8 now and and now I consider that
you know this is a new these operations
are defying all the integers and that
there and they're like these are
associative operations exclusive or and
not and you know this bitwise end
because our exclusive or there are also
CEO of operations we can mix them with
with plus and minus and and imagine that
we teach this to everybody I mean you
know and we can we have a whole system
that we go beyond ordinary arithmetic
and just have a richer collection of
things to do and so you start looking at
at this and mathematicians
have found a small number of uses of
this exclusive or operation but they
never studied the little bit wise and a
bitwise or but but there's some some
nice theories about about exclusive or
that that they are you specially in the
theory of games but but also there are
there are interesting identities in fact
for example X plus 2 exclusive or 3
minus 2 is equal to X minus 2 exclusive
or 3 plus 2 now that's not obvious but
it just happens to be true and and it's
an open problem actually to take two to
solve the yet the if somebody writes
down a formula involving plus plus minus
and exclusive or to tell you whether
it's an identity for all integers but
but but certain classes of the problem
are no now let's check this out just
test to test to make sure so I'll make a
table of X here and I say we go 0 1 2 3
I claim it's for true for all all in the
Jews egg and so i'll write x plus 2 here
and then i will exclusive or with three
okay well you can i'm going to go
negative 2 why not so 0 plus two is you
know two three four we can do we can add
20 I don't think we'll have much problem
with that minus two plus two minus one
plus two so so we get this now we got a
two exclusive or with three so what
happens zero exclusive or three is three
one exclusive or three is two to 10 and
then for exclusive or three is seven six
five going like this minus one exclusive
or three what was it you remember minus
one is all one so exclusive or three
it's a whole bunch of ones followed by 2
to s minus four
ok now let's let's also take X minus 2
and exclusive or three with that so X
minus two is your minus five minus four
minus three minus two minus 10 12 for
example and Ally exclusive or that would
three and we already have these answers
so in fact we can see what's going on
here so exclusive over three here we get
three and then here we had a minus four
minus two exclusive looking well this
has got to be one bigger so it's come
it's got to be minus three minus two
minus one and then this will be minus
eight we had minus five a minute ago
it's this guy so we take occlusive or
three we get it ends with 30 4-8 ok and
one exclusive or three you know let's do
okay so now if you look at that these
numbers there just for apart and so you
can see that if I you know if I put this
over here i get i get a plus four over
here so this is indeed a serious
identity involving these things but
there are other identities i have thrown
in bitwise and and oren things like they
end up so you know we enriched
mathematics we might as well learn learn
about this system but very few people
have ever started yeah testings
identities like this is open you mean
that's not known whether it's computable
earth rom pine oil or butter you're
actually not sure what's not known oh
let's see it was John Conway who told me
this once at lunch but but why and I
don't have all the pages here let's see
here I've got a level 46 research
problem which you can look at can we get
this on the hope ok this guy here
incidentally this in an exact I'll have
a interesting graphic work where you
just plot the x squared Y and
right 11 and you get this very
interesting pattern and one of the
exercise is to explain why you get these
worlds quickly okay so the results of
exercise 15 make it possible decide
whether or not any two given animating
functions are equal animating functions
are functions that that alternate + + +
exclusive or with with constants and
there's a normal form for that and you
can do is there an algorithm decides
whether any given expression is
identically zero expression is
constructed from finite number integer
variables and constants using only the
binary so this is that this is a
decision problem so actually whether
it's unsolvable or sellable it is open I
believe yeah and I got this from John
Conway who was the person who solved the
animating function proud the problem he
calls him animating for his own reason
so it has to do with the pain with NIM
okay so um now these operations get more
important because nowadays when we had
when that 64-bit computers are very
common so we have more bits if we had
only you know 8 bit registers then
wouldn't be that interesting to do
bitwise operations because you could you
could do a bit by bit without much that
much different but when you mean to 64
bits at a time we're getting a factor 64
and that's nothing to sneeze it and so
we're good people are now starting to
look at what what we can do with these
operations on bigger and bigger on
bigger bigger number and so before I get
further about my plan today is to show
you a whole bunch of really cool packs
and and and some of which are tricks and
some of which are techniques most of
which are techniques on and that Andy
and then you can you can you know learn
learn the whole thing later at your
leisure interest but when I started when
I started seeing how many there are and
and
and then week after week learning yet
more amazing things that are possible
with these operation I thought oh boy
there ought to be a name for for this
kind of study and so and and there was
one name in in the literature but I
don't even want to write it down because
it was for me it was a non-starter I can
tell you though if you don't breathe it
out of this room it's you one of my one
of my former students Mike Redmond wrote
a paper with Dan Willard about 15 years
ago where they decided that they wanted
to call this trance dichotomous
computing um and okay I looked it up in
google and i found that that you know
somebody the following year wrote a
paper that had trans like adam is in the
title but fortunately it's it's tied out
the last six last 13 years there hasn't
been anybody else or at least last 10
years apart i know using that word so I
want to have a nut but I figured
concepts important enough I want to I
want to have a have a name for it and
also as i'm going to say later on in
this lecture I think it might have
implications for hardware design of new
kind of computers in the future so so I
also look there and when one possible
thing would be VL DW because if people
have designed computers with a very
large instruction word and they call
those vliw machines but I google this
and this this has already taken by very
large data warehouses so you know so you
can't use that ok so um I asked Leo
kiba's my student who's sitting up here
with the with a sheepish grin and and
and I said you know I I want I want to
use Greek roots and and so I I don't
remember what word i gave him but I
combined some greek word some greek
roots and i said how does this on to you
leo and he said it you know basically it
stinks but
he said Plato logic is a winner pedro
logic sounds good to a greek person and
it comes from Greek roots meaning wide
and word okay actually plate ology let's
say is the you know the psychology is
the study of wide words now this has
nothing to do with a Greek philosopher
whose names some of you might might
remember you know if this happens I hit
his name also come from this this route
that that means Y and logos would be
people know like a Greek come from there
so so anyway this is but but I think the
connection with Plato is you know I mean
okay so it's it's misunderstood but it
actually is it's so much easier to
remember the word because you know that
you don't have that you have any help
Plato logic it just sounds so it sounds
like it's a word that all who have been
here for years and so it so any kind of
got to say if you were the downside of
it is is that plate ology is a noun and
Plato logic is an adjective not a nod so
I say Plato logic computing I didn't say
you know building a computer out of
Plato logic it's like syntactic you know
if I could say Plato logical as well but
it just died in it aakriti extra
syllable I don't usually use syntactical
isolation tactic and so and you know
physical okay you got music is now but
but we have receipt X anyway so this is
an adjective and you can also say you
know an adverb Plato logically and
things like this about anyway it might
not fly it's only has a better name I'll
you know know but but I feel the concept
needs a name and this is this is this is
the winner so far that I know okay so
that's that's reason for the
for the foot for the title now let me
show you some now the reek now I think
the first person who really began to to
take the covers off as some of the
possibilities for foreplay told logic
computing was Bill Gosper he published a
famous sequence of instructions in 1972
in famous memo hack men went came out on
februari 29th 1972 at MIT and gossipers
hack Oh was a sequence of seven
operations that i will write down for
you and explain and but what happened is
after i like in a way God's was hacked
changed the world because after gospel
after we realized that gospel hack
existed then all of a sudden said well
maybe there's other hacks to like this
that we can do things that we never
thought we could do with these bitwise
operation so here is God's protect you
started with a number X and you set u
equal to X and minus X and then you set
V 2x plus you and finally you set y tu v
exclusive oh I'm sorry v plus the
exclusive or x divided by you or / for
you let's say another word shift shift
right to so so here is this is this is a
one operation to subtract another one to
take the and that's two operations three
operations here's of four operations for
the exclusive or five to the pleasant
whoops the division is six but Evan one
two three four five six seven yeah shift
right to school but what's going on here
this is what this is one operation to
operations three four five six and seven
yeah six is for the division in and
seven is for the shift right T so you
can also
let me call this V exclusive or x / you
shift right 27 operation now um I told
you a minute ago about how do you get
minus X from X remember that and look
what happens if you take the end of
these two guys you get one and all just
get a 1 in the position where where X is
smallest one was okay incredibly useful
operation I think Gosper was the first
to notice this but anyway I haven't seen
anything before 1972 wear this wear this
particular trick technique was of the
play but so if you want to know that you
know the the smallest one that expects
it out there so let's let's take a
typical example of a number X and
suppose X is equal to well the loop is
you see you already gave me a gig let me
go through the second row here car ones
and zeros to what 1 0 0 1 1 1 1 0 0 1 1
this is cool random we got it okay we've
got to have none in go ahead one and got
out a few more zeros that's all right
anyway it wasn't completely playing out
so this is X so what's you well you is
going to be a one city here I be as I
told you because minus X is going to is
going to be 0 0 1 0 1 0 once all the way
around so this is you okay now what's v
well X plus you it's 10 11 100 now the
one got added in here and it carries
over like that okay now the next thing
is we take V exclusive over X the
exclusive or X so what
so something has changed here 111 right
now we / you that shifts it over you is
just a power too so if this is a this is
a strange way of normalizing the thing
bringing the thing those three ones all
to the right and by the way I have to
put parentheses around this whole
business and so now I add that to be and
I get what you say boy I got a shift
right shift right by to right so now I
shift right by two and and I only got
one left now i add VV + and I'm getting
1 0 1 1 1 0 0 0 1 all right so that's
that's why now notice that why has 51
bits in it and X has 51 that's in it
well it turns out this is the smallest
number bigger than X it has 51 bits in
so it's about X to this do it again your
shift is on overlap 11 priscilla and so
on it will you run through all the not
all the integers that have exactly five
one bit if you start out with the
smallest one which is you know 31 ok
that's it cosmas hat I introduced as an
exercise a sequence of nested
parentheses encoded by zeros and ones
and and I was able to do out Casper
Casper by having evenness divided by the
square root of you in my in my formula
but anyway that's it this was as I said
this is an eye-opener to know that we
could do something like there
and it's just the beginning just the
beginning okay now um I i guess i can
show next um yeah let's let's talk about
okay so so how do you make this into a
into a technique and one of the first
things that is to just to study how to
operate at the right hand out of a word
which is what this what this is and so
working with with these bits one of the
things that we that we wouldn't we start
to learn the about it pretty soon people
are talking about we call the ruler
function which is if you have an integer
that isn't zero the ruler function says
how many zeros there are at the right
the number of trailing zeros of the
thing and the reason we caught the ruler
function is because if you zoom in on
you see how are the tick marks on the
ruler get like this you see the ruler
function if if you have an odd number of
the ruler function is zero but if it but
if you have twice an odd number the
ruler function is 1 and if you have four
times an odd number that's two and so on
so the length of the tick marks done you
know goes like the ruler function it's
up and one of the interest profits the
water function is that the ruler
function of X minus y is the ruler
function of X exclusive or why and so on
so we start thinking about the ruler
function which talks about number of of
trailing one a number of ones at the
right are zeros treading zeros at the
right then there's a corresponding dual
function in the lambda function which is
the which is the integer part of binary
logarithm of X which tells you where the
leftmost one is in an integer a positive
integer negative integer has so many one
said that there is no leftmost but this
is the leftmost one and it's kind of
nice that lambda is for left and ruler
is foreign rose for is for right easy to
remember these number numbers ok so
well a lot of the things that week that
we try to do then are based on an
understanding of of ways to deal with
the with the bits that are at the right
and bits in are at the left and um it's
it it seems to be a lot harder to work
at the left and at the right because
when you're adding adding stuff together
you got carries propagating to the left
but we met we don't have anything that
propagates to the right in the same way
and a lot of the fear the basic theory
of this of this subject is still is
still filled with open questions but and
so for example I can't prove to you that
there is no that there's no efficient
way to extract the leftmost bit the way
i extracted the rightmost bit remember I
X and minus X is the is the rightmost
bit about zero i have no proof that
there isn't that tomorrow somebody isn't
going to come up with a sequence of 12
steps that is going to give me the
leftmost bit i just haven't been able to
think of it but i haven't able to think
of a way to prove that that's impossible
um I do have some lower bounds just
saying if I'm going to compute the the
number of zeros so if I'm going to
compute the position of this of this
number to actually compute the logarithm
the lambda X then I then I know it's
difficult to a certain point and if I
have if I have n bit words I know it
takes log log n steps to do that but to
compute one to compute 2 to the power
lambda X might be simple I have no I I
know of no reason no reason why it's
impossible but I strongly doubt it um ok
so we're going to land enroll functions
but there's a there's a a great a great
trick of which that which I I
I realized must be true earlier this
year and I told my friend bill lynch
about it and I said you know it it seems
to be difficult to figure to compute
lambda X but if you're given x and y two
different numbers and you want to know
whether lambda x equals lambda y that's
easy I don't know how to calculate
lambda x fest I don't know the calculor
limit life ice but I can I can I know
how to calculate whether one is he so I
so I tried I met my my former colleague
bill inch at a party earlier this year
and I told him my height I just
discovered that it's easy to do this
today and give it to him as a puzzle and
he sends back by email a solution it was
much better than mine and so the incense
Oh bill bill said this is true if and
only if X exclusive or y is less than or
equal x and y so and I think about it if
you know if they if they are the same
meeting bit position and then I take the
exclusive or that zeroes out that bit
position but the end still has the one
in that big position and converse also
closed but works at that time okay so so
we can test fast whether it is true
another similar thing my friend Tamra
quickie came up with a similar idea but
related and that is up I won't talk much
about the reversal but but the other
thing that people always do with their
bit plays out is to try to to flip a
number left to right now here it's not
an infinite precision integer but but
maybe we have a 64-bit integer so we
want to take the bits you know ABCD and
so on and around so that the a is that
they're right and the B&B is it and
beans going the other direction and and
download pic you need when we find that
page here
to that X to find out whether the
reversal of X is is is is less than the
reversal of Y is something you can do
quickly without testing without
reversing X or reversing y and the and
the reason and what you do is you set D
equals X minus y and y minus X and then
you test d + + y equals D so you know X
minus y + + y minus X now this is a you
know remember this is some quantity and
it's negative and so this is the this is
the least bit of X minus y this is the
rightmost one bit of X minus y and so if
that if that happens to be you know
that's the place where Y is 1 and X is
zero so if it happens that we intersect
that bit with y and we get and we
haven't zeroed it out and then it must
be that that what that wife has a 1 in
that day so so when x and y are reverse
you see they'll have other bits that
cancel out to the right so anyway this
is another surprising fact that without
reversing numbers I can tell what would
have happened if i compare the two and
andrew kicky found a great use for this
because he he loves x and y be the bv
the address of nodes in a binary search
tree and this Turk this is kind of a
random a randomization which helps him
keep the binary first rebalanced and he
said that that this improved the speed
of a program that he was Packard by a
several orders of magnitude when he
could this is just a couple lines it and
so anyway this is a another known a
quick story ok now lets up how could I
want to get to some smoke some more
mindful stuff so
go next um 11 idea that is too cool to
to omit is is this one knows about the
next if you think I'm going to be
talking about is where I we're working
on individual bytes so imagine that I
got a 64 bit word and it's divided into
eight bytes or in general you have
imagined you have some wide word and
it's divided into a small number of
fields or a smaller number of fields and
those fields are we want to sort of work
on all of those fields simultaneously
but but the individual feels I'm
supposed to mess up the other ones and
so the the next trick I want to show you
is this is due to Hank deets and it's to
take the average of corresponding bytes
so I have a word x that's that has the
eight bytes x 1 x 2 up to x 8 in a
64-bit word and y is y 1928 and I want
to get Z which you know Z 1 through z 8
where z j is equal to the average of XJ
plus YJ over to like like like average
these guys up at no sort so of course I
want to do some kind of something like
addition here's the here's the dietz's
formula first of all I set Z to X
exclusive or Y and L bar I'll explain
this in a minute and shift right one and
then I take then i take x and y and add
it to that guy so let's call this tea
instead so that's not to confuse the
issue so so i compute a temporary number
which is exclusive or ended with the
with this L bar and shifted right one
tell you what lk l is an l is actually
111 it's a one it's a one at the right
position at the right every bite it's
simply a little bit there's eight of
them though one two three four five six
seven so L has L is it if it is a little
bit there and so if you so what's
happened here I exclusive or at x and y
and then I ended with a saying that you
don't have a little bit on so so that
means I'm zeroing out a little bit so
that when I shifted right one it's not
going to go into the wrong field so
that's it that's easy enough so what
I've done is I've exclusive or these
guys and shifted them right one well
then I end it and add that to add that
to T and it's just another way of
writing the the well-known formula that
to add to binary numbers you get it is
ex exclusive or y plus the carries and
the Carrey's are x and y shifted shifted
left one and if you if you're adding two
binary numbers together you take the
explicit form and you also have to have
to have to add in the carries this is a
plus sign to but now we're dividing by 2
so really I wanted the shift you know I
wanted to shift this look right by one
and not ship this by one so that's what
I've got here so I mean take the floor
by shifting right one so so that's the
but it it's a formula you know that I
that is so simple once you've seen it
but but you say why didn't I think of
that you know okay okay um but more
often I think apocryphal too we have a
lot of bites we're doing something where
we want to say search through a whole
bunch of ice and quickly decide whether
what not one of the bikes is 0 for
example you know I think you all know
the way the way programming languages
like C and I'm sure Java to keep keep
track of screens they store characters
and then then put a zero of a null
character at the end and that instead of
saying somewhere else how long the
string is they just so no here's where
the spring starts and it ends at the
first zero wherever that happens to be
okay so let's imagine that we want to
figure out what's what this what the
length of a string is and of course it's
obviously look at the first character is
it zero no go on the second character
third character until we until we find a
zero but well this is taking few
instructions for every character be nice
if we could sort of just glance that
eight characters at once to say we have
a 64-bit machine and say is there any
zero thing in here uh you know if not go
on to the next okay well here's a is to
think it took foreign it took four or
five instructions to do that there's you
can do it with three so x is equal to
eight eight eight bytes and now i want
to see if any of these is zero and what
you do is you are you compute H and X
minus l and X bar 1230 now H is the is
is a is a I'll write it in octal
notation it's 80 80 80 80 it's a one in
the hype hi bit position of every field
and l is is hexadecimal 01 i write this
four hexadecimal instead of the oh x
that succeed language that's long k so
so somehow H has a one bit in that the
top of every bite and L has a one bit at
the bottom of every bite and let's see
what happens here well if there if there
aren't any zeros in word I claim that
it's we're going to get zero here so so
every one of these bites it is nonzero I
suppose for social you know okay so
what's happening then well i subtract
like I subtract one from that bite and
get X minus L and I've lost you know I
haven't borrowed into it into anywhere
else I guess I had some nonzero number I
practive one from it is still zero or
positive right then I I look at I and it
with with the compliments of this number
so that means that I have to have a I
have to have a bit that was zero before
subtracting one but one after
subtracting 1 i'm sorry yeah it has to
have a one after subtracting one because
I because I'm Andy try to have a one
from this and I have to have one from it
but which meant a zero originally so so
it's like I've had a bit that went that
was zero but after ice corrected one
went to a one yeah right but it also so
so so how can how can that be that that
um you know if I if I had a number like
X is 1 0 1 0 1 1 0 0 and i subtract one
and i get 1 0 1 0 1 0 0 1 you know and
right 10 11 good thank you and and so i
would add you know so this is X this is
X minus 1 or X minus L in your interview
and then i have x bar is of course 0 1 0
1 0 0 1 1 and so I i'm sitting here with
1 1 0 0 0 0 0 now i'm adding this with h
which means that these ones have to go
all the way to the to the left it can't
happen so i'm getting 0 so you know
getting 0 if if all of these guys are
nonzero but if at least one is 0 let's
take the one at a cruise most closest to
the right and take a look at it you find
out that you get a 1 bit there let's
check it out you've got a zero there
well then you've got salt zero so i
subtracted one so i got all the ones
they're in
and it was enough to have to do it now
so just three operations does to give it
the test now instead of operations
loaded or God best is not exactly
leftmost 0 is so this is the first
example I know actually we're into like
a little Indian starring our way to
storing strings the way they the way I
mean I never understood why Intel did it
the way the way they do but but in this
case I can find the right nosebite by
looking at this number but but if I have
to get the leftmost fight I have to
compute another another quality with
four instructions that they will tell me
what the leftmost I did so well I don't
dwell on this too long but anyway here's
my point is that real quick we can we
can look at eight bytes at a time also
maybe we're not searching for the
question are you zooming that you can
get that a lot of us without of the
instructions and and yeah I'm assuming
that that that my hardware does allows
me to do and not in one instruction now
this is not true on all machines
unfortunately but you know next you know
it is soon will be I mean soon as people
know all these tricks it there they're
not going to go see stupid machine right
now right now in order to get an not on
an Intel machine you have to you have to
put it into a floating point register
and use the you know and you have to set
some flags and things like this it's
ridiculous but you know on a decent
computer whichever of you know like the
PowerPC you thought me and Lauren so um
so you know nips whatever you should
have all these are my my operation
County soon
uh yeah yo na what's up you know i'm
sticking with stupid conventions about
the machines that we haven't have right
now I mean I also you know the defined
division correctly instead of the way
most computers work ok so now give you
another example here um let's suppose
well maybe we aren't searching for zero
maybe want to find the first occurrence
of some letter in a long string you know
we're doing text searching so uh you
know looking for the first occurrence of
it or come clarity like a dollar sign so
find the first dollar sign in this text
all right well what you do is you take
the word x and u exclusive or with eight
dollar signs and then you look 40 all
right so open now now let me give you
another example this one was actually
given by Leslie Lamport who wrote the
who wrote one of the rare articles about
this subject caper was published I I'm
not sure 76 or something like this when
he worked at at park maybe I don't know
what anyway up but he ki wrote one of
the first papers I've discussed this
kind of thing but he didn't know that
these tricks such good tricks existence
so he actually took every bite and
extended 29 bit but his paper suggested
this this application so here we have I
suppose I have X sub and and y and these
are you know bites and then then I want
Z now in this case the rule is z j is
equal to XJ if x and y are equal but
it's equal to an asterisk if they're not
equal okay so if they're equal you could
choose either exit or why they so so for
example you start out with the word like
like the exes beaching
and why is belching then Z is be itching
that's the problem is to convert
beaching and belching to the kitchen now
here's the here's the here's the code t
is equal to disk H this high bit thing
and with and then you take the exclusive
or of x and y or exclusive or of x + y +
h minus L you know the nikkei we're not
going to go through in detail you have
to believe me on this one this gives me
something it's that's ears that's ended
with H and so it's going to sew in every
bike where you're going to have a
leading one or not it and it's going to
be a one actually of x equals y in that
character and or is it going yeah if
they're unequal it's going to give us a
one and if their equals can be it's
going to be zero so then I form a mask m
by taking tea and left shifting at one
and subtracting T right shifting by
seven this is going to give me a mask
that is either are ones or all zeros in
each bike then I do this in the same
search an asterisk where where the thing
is mashed in it and it and it otherwise
it doesn't so that's the that's the
solution to this problem l 123 I've
already done that four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven instructions but
it's a you know harder to do vacuum we
did eight characters with 11 instruction
so it's not not too bad okay oh now the
I gotta exercise in here website which I
had great fun writing which shows that
we can go away beyond this to the
following in a six in six operations
suppose I have a number X that has six
fights at eight bytes to it and I'm
going to compute six operations on X I'm
going to I'm going to inclusive or with
a constant and then and call that Y then
I'm going to take Y and end it with B
and plus C another constant or that with
y exclusive or with d and and the whole
thing with e now i'm supposed to this
team this key is supposed to be a bunch
of flags shifted left seven each bite t
is supposed to start out with a one or a
zero based on on eight criteria and each
bite is different i'm actually numbering
the x 0 to seven instead of what 128
year the but so so in the leftmost in
the leftmost bite oh no i'm sorry the
rightmost bite here it's x 72 x 1 i'm
using uh you know isn't this notation
house this is you know base 256
arithmetic so in the rightmost bit by
time saying that the flag should be set
if the character is ! the next fight
over it's supposed to be set if the
character is not an asterisk the next
character its if it's if it's if it
comes less and ascii code then a capital
a the next one is if it comes greater in
ascii code than a lowercase Z and and
here's a greater than or equal to a
lowercase a that this one is whether
it's a the ASCII code for a decimal
digit 0 to 9 and here it's a case where
any any pipe that's less than or equal
to 1 68 and finally at the X 7 I the
flag should be set
if and only if it's one of these four
characters that represents a relation
less equal greater than or ? so so the
point is you can do that operation doing
eight eight different kinds of tests on
eight individual bytes in six operations
if you just if you just happen to know
the magic constants ABC B&E now why is
that true well if I had time I would
explain the answer to but you'll have to
look so so now so you know some of those
tests were the last and somewhere less
than or equal somewhere in a range
somewhat or unequal tester but we're
doing it all simultaneously obviously
okay now when we're doing instructions
of this kind the ROG I guess I want to
say a couple couple things quick Ellen
tolocamp remarked to me in 20 30 years
ago that people are building are putting
more and more gates on a chip now you
were getting n you know n logic loop
flops on ship where n keeps getting
larger and larger and larger but only if
you look at the tips only login of those
bit of those flip-flops are either
flipping or flopping you know hardly
anything is actually happening as far as
changing the state inside of inside of
the chips that we're building now you
know this is I mean I'm not talking
about a CPU chip but I'm talking about
mostly about a memory chip we're almost
nothing is Jenkins is there but these
these are built you know these are these
are large integrated circuits so not
much is happening it's so different from
the human brain where you know we got
all ourselves are somehow work and
working together and we're not saying
okay now you go so of course there's an
obvious source of inefficiency and
Hardware designers have been
working for years to to figure out how
we can do some how we can how we can do
something so we can handle this and get
luck make use of all that all the
potential power that's that's that's
there and so maybe this Plato logic
computing it Kyle will have some sucks i
will lead to some advances in this
direction and for this like I recommend
thinking of it as trying to imagine a
brand new kind of computer that has
smart we might think of it as having
smart memory so that we're not doing
these operations in registers but were
actually we're just saying to the memory
go ahead and do some logical ants on
what you have don't don't send it to me
to do the due to do the operation and so
I like to assume that we might be able
to build a machine that you know the
cycle time will be slower than the cycle
times we're now asking for but still the
words would be very wide and so we would
repeal the memory you know okay doing a
large part of your memory now and and do
a a bitwise exclusive or of these guys
or even Plus which which involves some
carry propagation and we also would want
to be able to shift by powers of two and
and and now we could you could combine
that with a normal memory and two but
just have these as a different for
purple so this is rather like what
something that people have studied for a
long time called cindy computer which is
a which wich is a parallel machine
standing for single instruction multiple
data where the cpu is giving
instructions and the and then out in the
and then two different pero units are
all are all operating on these
instruction and and so of
last 10 years or so there's been
researchers various pipe to the world
that are talking about what they call
SWA our computation this means simdi
within a register and and so they're
thinking yeah this stuff that we're that
we're doing here with belching and so on
that's very much likes like simdi but
we're doing it you know we're doing it
in it in our program so so we're using
the same D kind of approach but within a
register and and there is even it is
nice you know there's there's some
website but there's a compiler called a
soirée c compiler which where you can
give it a little bit some extension to
the c language and and and and it will
figure out some rather clever techniques
for for doing these operations without
without you having to figure them out
and it'll do some packing and unpacking
and clever stuff I said earlier though I
I think that's like time for these ideas
to go mainstream and for ordinary
programmers not have to go to a special
compiler for this and I know and I'm
hoping at some time we would you might
even be able to make use of these things
with really wide words not within a
register but in fact within within a
smart memory I'm doing Guzan calculation
Oh order to finish up i want to i want
to mention then to two things the first
one is mitzi Yaga I think I have time to
do part of it that so Ron Pratt came up
with this in the middle 70s and showed
that you can multiply boolean matrices
extremely fast using such a computer
let me let me explain it on a 64-bit
register so suppose I get suppose they
have some make I don't know aight i
could i could get it you know fairly
random idea but i can write down to four
by four matrices of zeros and ones for
whatever you want to put here and then i
can multiply these together there's two
ways to multiply 01 matrices one is the
boolean way and one is the modulo 2 but
anyway the first in either case this was
this would say take the fourth row is
100 on this one would say combine the
second row in the fourth row so if we
take a clue savour this would be 10 11
but if I took or I could take either
logical or or exclusive or here and this
is take the first row and this one says
to the bottom three rows exclusive or
the bottom three rows at 0 0 1 0 okay so
this is matrix multiplication mod 2 for
example but I could also have done okay
now I like to do this quickly on ax with
64-bit register so let's suppose that I
pack that I have my 64 bit register and
I and I I got three-quarters of it I 0
and here i put Carrie put the matrix so
i have 0 0 0 1 0 1 0 1 and so on down
here that's X and then now this is X and
then y and y will be 16-bit thing like
this as well as well and I'd like up to
and get Z in the same format with it's
very small number of instructions ok
well so let's let's suppose that this is
ABCD efg hijk LMNOP times a b c d e f g
h i j k l m n o p equals and then i'm
not going to write out the whole thing
but as a a B plus BB this exclusive or
plus b e+ see i plus
the m and the other other 15 entries are
similar so matrix multiplication better
it's starting out with a b c d e f g h i
j k or up to pee and and a through p in
that's lets up done it here's the here's
the solution first off we say x is set
to X or X left shift 16 and then X then
after doing that I then I also shift
left 32 so the first time I take this
and I shift left 16 and so I get two
copies of it and I take this and I
shifted 32 and I get copies so since I
have now built the register with that
goes a through p a through PA through p
a through p 4 times same thing for why
some slight I've got four got my
matrices replicated four times the next
thing I want to do is up swapping bits
that are 15 apart and I'm going to
change X so that I got a a cc ee so on
00 and and then it's going to have BB DD
and end with PP and NN start AAC Cee and
so on like this so so so these are these
are 32 bits and 32 more bits in X and
how do I get from here to here well I
have to I have to swap this a with this
be and I have to swap this see with this
be and so then then this you then I'm
sorry not that guy I want to swap the D
with this with this guy so some pairs of
elements that are 15 apart I want it I
want to swap you can do that by taking X
exclusive or X right shift 15 that
shifts everything right 15 and then you
and with some masks which which has a
1-bit hit you at the right position of
the guy you want to you want to flip and
then you can say X is set to ex
exclusive or I'm sorry T exclusive RT
left shift what is it exes um ok yeah x
is x e left shift 15 this puts after
I've matched it off in this position
i'll have a exclusive or B in this
position I'll have see exclusive or D
and I'll have zeros elsewhere then I
take that number and I shifted left 15
and so what I'm doing is I'm changing
the be to an a here and the and and this
a to a be here because I'm exclusive ok
i am taking eight exclusive or B and
adding it to her excelling at tube to be
and that changes I mean be be with a
plus B is a & a with a plus B is B so so
sorry these this is what one two three
four five six operations swaps guys that
are 15 apart ones that I want I choose
this ok and and and then I can shoot I
can do it again with things are 30 apart
and I can get aaaaa eeeee or something
like this with another with another swap
so I I can arrange things so that i'm
sitting here with x equals aaaaa eeeee
and it's going to end up i'm going to
have each of the
I'm going to have the columns e IM then
be FJ 10 with DHL p it's going to have
pppp on the right with a similar pattern
but instead of using 15 and 30 I you use
12 and 24 it turns out you can get y
equals ABCD 8f ABCD ABCD ABCD and then
you can go efg HTF ghghghghgh and so on
ending up with mnop but these are caps
cap ABCD so these are the elements of
why but with a little bit of shifting
and and exclusive o-ring masking I can
get that I can get the first row
repeated four times and then the second
row repeated four times and ending up
with mnop the last row repeated four
times now i compute x and y and i'm
doing simultaneously 64 and operations
so here I'm getting a a and then I'm
getting a B and AC and so on all the way
up to pee pee and now I look at this and
it turns out that all i have to do is it
is take these these for 16-bit things
and I take these 32 and I exclusive or
to these 32 and then I take these an
exclusive all of these and I've got the
matrix product so i had to go through
fast but the point is that i've used it
if I had to to the D but by 2 to the D
matrices I do 18 d + 2 bitwise
operations and I've got the product um
and that so usually you know you talk
about time for matrix multiplication and
by n matrix is n cubed this is log in
with a fairly small constant of
proportionality so
so if you can we take d equals 6 so
there's 64 x 64 matrices so I so that's
2 to the 12 that's 4,000 some bits all
together and in the other matrix there's
another for thousands I've got eight
thousand bits of these matrices and I'm
doing 6 times 18 for 100 and 108 hundred
and ten operations I'm on these eight
thousand bits not with a hundred ten
operations you know that's only 18 80th
as many bits as there are bits i
multiplied these matrices together now
how big was my register my register is
two to the D cubed so I actually sitting
here with an 18-bit to to the 18th bits
register so I'm sitting here with rather
wide words these are two hundred and 256
kilobytes but you know heart memory
could do this and its variant mark and
with the lowest type cycle climbing and
so you know you could and and they also
showed many other operations in Pratt
and start mark showed that many other
operations could be done efficiently
with with it with this kind of
organization all right click done so the
last the last example well go through it
or not and then I promise to say
something about about this lambda
function and so and so I think I can do
it but if you wanted if you want to
leave go ahead because you know I know
that it's I've already spoken for an
hour and 10 minutes so here here here's
the idea up I suppose I want to
calculate lambda of X this is the i want
to i want to know where is the leading
one of X remember I told you this was
this is the seem to be a tough problem
and let me assume that x is 0 is only 16
bits long
I can I can reduce the 64-bit problem to
our a 16-bit problem with a couple you
know by like by looking at the four
parts of the words so now I've got a
little bit of breathing room if i have
if i have a 16-bit number and and so so
x is a 16-bit number and let's suppose X
for example is 0 0 0 1 and then 12 other
bits that I don't know what they are now
i'm going to make four copies of this
number X so I put I got 0 0 0 1 here and
you know you know anyway i'll put a card
alpha and i have alpha alpha alpha alpha
and and now i'm going to not going to
form another magic magic constant here
and the constant looks like this the
first part all right it in well I'll
brightened by a 1 1 1 188 ones and eight
zeros then the next one has four ones
four zeros for one's for zeros and then
to one's two zeros and so on over and
over again I'm getting tired of this and
then one 10 10 10 10 ok so in
hexadecimal it's FF 0 0 f 0 f 0 CC CC
and a AAA is this is this constant here
and so I'm going to I'm going this is my
magic constant m for magic and then I'll
so this is X replicated and so now I'd
say y is equal to x + M so so what's so
why is going to have four parts to it y0
y1 y2 y3 y0 is is going to X let's say
start out with 3300 one
so it's going to repeat is going to
start out looking like 300 one that's
going to have four unknowns and it's
going to have 80 this is y0 y1 is going
to start out 00 01 and and and then zero
four zeros and then four unknowns and
four zeros and y2 is going to be 0 0 0 0
and then two unknowns two zeros two
unknowns two zeros to unknown because
and y3 is going to be start out with
four zeros and it's going to be like
this so I'm getting I'm getting some
quick crazy number by taking this X here
ending it with this with this a strange
mask which happens to be truth tables of
different of different projection
functions well now be the are the basic
idea because I showed you that there's a
that there's an easy way to test I'm the
x equals lambda Y that was remember that
was if and only if X if you take the XR
it's less than or equal to the to the
logical and the bit ly then and so now
I've also got these techniques that were
introduced by land port which allow us
to check whether one but whether one
bite is less than another bite
corresponding fields and so what i can
do is simultaneously test to see whether
if i if i throw out numbers whose whose
lambda has has a 1 in its you know
lambda is it's a binary number in it and
it's got four bits to it so if i can
calculate i can calculate whether lambda
is even or I
by throwing out all of the all the
odd-numbered bits and seeing if I've
changed lambda and I can tell whether
lambda X has it has a 2 in its in its
but inspiring expansion by by by
throwing out all our leading bits that
are that are in positions that have two
in there in your expansion so then if I
can test if you know if I can test that
comparison but compare the exclusive-or
with the end of these functions are then
I'll know whether the bit was 0 or 1 and
that's the point of this of this others
exercise and so I'm throwing up so by
taking this this magic constant I'm
actually forming some some changing our
XO out the the bottom line is that i can
just show you the formula don't want to
get my pages out of order so i'll do it
this way this is page 1 of the 96 ok so
say the magic magic formula is this I I
I this was my funny m here and then I
take H and I intersect it with why or
why or H minus X occlusive or why and
where H has is high 1 bits in it and
then that gives me the of that I needed
and end up and then you can show gets to
the right and collect them so it turns
out that other word this is a competitor
this is competitive with the way known
to calculate the position of the bid of
a number and it took a shin in log log n
steps so this there's an obvious way to
do it in log n but this is log log n
which is very good because log log n
never exceeds 5
if n is so big that log log n is 6 then
we've already exceeded the size of the
universe so so it's that you know it's
an example again then with that even if
we allow our words to get bigger we can
do we can do non non trivial calculation
so once we understand this technique
well for my last I just want to show you
this so you can look up in the paper in
98 here this is these are 21 21 the
logic steps that that do a calculation
that that might what Mike Patterson and
I came up with this we were trying to
prove that something was going to take
log n steps and we found out we could do
it with the constant number of steps and
the and the problem was that we were
taking a look at a binary number and we
wanted to find where it had a zero
followed by our ones in a row where r is
some given number so like you know zero
followed by 82 ones and I want to I want
to I want to put that one mark all the
zeros that have this property that
they're followed by x 82 or more one and
and that problem is equivalent to two
saying I want X bar and X shift by 1 and
accepted by 2 and so on up to X shifted
by 81 in other words the number of you
know I want I want this to be a zero and
I want to leave like all these guys to
be one so to find this pattern it looks
like we're going to you know to
calculate this we would need something
like log our steps where we could sort
of brute these by two but to our
amazement we found that of this these 21
steps actually you know we kept trying
to disprove it until we find it until we
finally had a method that took 60 steps
and we cut it down to 40 and then we cut
it down to 30 and we could have gone to
15 and then it didn't work and we had to
add a few more so so so so this is just
not you know so so it's
um it's just another indication that
there's probably more things out there
and it's very hard to prove that you
can't do something with these operations
are powerful and I find that I keep
running into more cases in my programs
where I where it can use this so this
part is not going to be just about the
fasting but I also study applications to
graph theory to bitmap graphics and you
know I I used it to calculate gaps
between primes I just I just found out
that I that I set some World Records on
that regard because by using this kind
of operations and I think if everybody I
would not know these things are their
programs would get better so that's what
I had to say but for today thanks for
listening
happy to answer questions question it
seems to me that is the naive will
provide the ruler function is easy and
the lambda function is hard is that
you've got this vacation operator that
does most of the work for you negation
operator yeah and I'm wondering if that
means that the mutation operator is in
practice would be somewhat could help to
implement or whether there would be some
so so actually what one can electrical
engineers have have implemented the
negation upper now you could imagine a
computer where somebody give you a a
dual nut negation operator you know
numbers carries propagate the other way
today's propagate to the right so on and
Mike and I say well what if we had such
a machine you know yet they're not and
so so we have lower bounds saying that
in order to reverse bits it takes log n
steps that's a that's a nice theorem
proved by Milt erson and Monroe and and
so bit reversal is known to be it you
know is known to take some extra time so
if we built a machine that that also
allowed us to do this then we could do
the lambda operation faster and maybe
you know why not maybe maybe we should
build a machine that also allows p you
know to add vertically instead of
horizontally or something like that you
know look weak me because people know
how to build those circuits and so that
might make a lot of I think that now now
in MX computer I I threw in instructions
that that will debt that have built in
matrix multiply instruction on eight on
on 64-bit words and when you combine
that with with with these other things
exclusive or and so on then all of a
sudden you find that you can compute
cyclic parity codes faster you can
multiply polynomials and you can do all
kind of
kind of other or other thing the
question is probably what is the small
number of primitives that that will you
know that each have power but you can
keep adding more and more more and more
operations but the this this one matrix
multiply your unified seven or eight
instructions on the outfit on the Alpha
computer for example and ended more than
the Alpha your head so so so it but in
order to design this it got the new kind
of a computer is going to take a genius
I haven't worked out the problems by any
means but I but I'm just saying this is
food for thought that why can't we have
a smart memory may be doing these things
because the engineers have figured out
how to how to do conventional memories
maybe yeah you know it's not going to be
that much harder for them to add now we
got better technology not to to make the
memories to do more for us this son yeah
I we can also swapped the value of two
variables without using it the variables
of by only using off XOR yeah that's a
beaut yeah that's a beautiful pic that
that's that that's well known you take X
2 X X or Y to X Y in this to end this
does it it's lab section or something
what Allison equal already didn't get 0
I can hear unless x and y did already
well then they get well these are the
aliasing no idea i'm assuming that that
I can't do this with a sub I and SJ
so jumpy mom his colleagues back in the
80s built programmable active memories
which would have been able to do a fair
amount of this stuff I'm not sure
whether that line of of engineering but
there anything came out of it or not oh
you know about it i I didn't I hadn't
heard about I I mean I know he started
working on RSA chips this is probably
good for they are yeah yeah that was
later Yeah right so he but I mom but I'm
referring to demons work ok another
another thing I'm discussing here is
what we call implicit data structures
where we're instead of having pointer
you a lot of things we have data
structures that you can compute your way
to the other part of the structure
instead of instead of linking instead of
needing explicitly like a heap where
where you know that the father of node k
is the parent of node k is k 0 is k
shifted right one and the children are 2
k plus 1 and T k plus 1 and and a tense
and so I talked about what i call a
sideways heap which is another way of
that doesn't seem to be as well-known
includes data structure and i also have
us had a lot of fun with imprisoned data
structures based on hyperbolic geometry
which which are pretty weird but that
but not but it you can you can use
bitwise operations to find your way
around and a data structure without not
so much memory and these are these is
another important use of this kind of
this kind of thing not know now vmac
constrict worked on on get on unifying
data structures and in those days and
and so i'm referring to that work of his
but i don't know but i didn't know this
the pros of course if that was done in
the early 80s then that they wouldn't
had that the ability to build which
machines anyway and you were like just
that we can do with inputs present day
technology right it was implemented with
that DJ's I add on hard is that I soon
the implanted hands with effigy yeah
yeah well I got ya I don't see what
where these techniques are going to
would make Katherine any faster we
should believe so you know it's not
gentle purposes like there's lots of
programs that problems that it solves
really well but but I can't say that
that you know if I had a that I would be
able to to a lot of these other things
that people want for fast fourier
transform they can village ship that's
just good professor you transform so so
so i have i never been any good at
figuring out where the stuff is is if
commercially useful has any has any
financial value i'm also excited by the
ideas are underlying it and so on but
they but it seems to me that this is
that detect has enormous untapped
potential that that could very well lead
to a way to make use of this of the fact
that dr. that we need a good way to make
smarter memories if we want to if we
want to use things to their to their
potential yeah there was a near a
computer in late 60s Oh what God there
was a any of our computer in the sixties
that had a bit reversed back with a bit
reverse instruction because all the
vendors for the Navy were screwing up I
oh and finding captain grace hopper said
that the hell is it every driver has a
load register no up or it reversed and
then output I soon where there was a
typewriter or printer or whatever and I
see all these vendors were all messing
up little endian rocking it
little-endian big Indian I know it is
is it isn't but but switching switch
swapping all and bits instead of just
bites i'm not sure if i hate fake it was
just a bit yeah but the yeah that's uh
that's done by one instruction on em mix
of course but the matrix multiply oh
yeah when looking at the complexity of
these operations I wonder if you make
sense to distinguish the boolean
operations and plus minus and negation
because on the hardware level they have
different complexity especially for
example on Matthews operations to FPGAs
they have also different Layton sees
plasma the the fact that carries have to
propagate makes it it makes it makes
addition definitely harder that then but
then boolean operations I saw for sure
but but it's still in the class of that
they call AC 0 which means that the
complexity grows polynomial e with the
with the with the logarithm of the of
the of the size what multiplication is
not multiplication stuff is is is is way
above that so so the D but this is it's
something that I thought I should state
that assuming that I can do add in one
cycle time because is is much more
difficult than saying I can do bitwise
and in one cycle time there are very
efficient ways to do a carry propagation
that don't exist for multiplication in
addition but they still are much more
complex sentence in
a simple one bit at a time oh thanks for
gas